la question qui est posée c'est surtout
les déclarations de monsieur le maire
monsieur darmanin concernant les aides
sociales liées à l'emploi et là je dis
attention danger
je ne veux pas qu'on touche à la prime
d'activité je ne veux pas qu'on touche à
la garantie jeunes pour les jeunes plus
en difficulté je ne veux pas qu'on
touche aux contrats aidés
toute une série de mesures que nous
avons porté accompagné des emplois
d'avenir aussi pour pour les jeunes et
je m'attarderai peut-être sur la prime
d'activité puisque manifestement elle
est dans le collimateur deux millions de
français en bénéficient
5 milliards d'euros de dépenses en 2017
je ratais explose
je rappelle quand même qu'elle a
remplacé un système qui était totalement
inefficients qu'on appelait le rsa
activité
vous avez oublié sûrement mais qui
existe est créée par nicolas sarkozy et
la fameuse ppe prime pour l'emploi
aujourd'hui cette prime d'activité est
un véritable déclencheur pour inciter à
l'emploi la remettre en cause serait une
erreur d'autant plus que cette prime qui
varient entre 100 et 150 euros suivant
des foyers n'est pas thésauriser elle
n'est pas mise sur un plan d'epargne en
actions elle est bien sûr quand on les
smicards elle est dépensé dans
l'économie les gens qui est réel travail
à la question
de notre sondage opinionway était celle
ci les aides sociales sont elles une
trappe à chômage est bien pour 55% des
français oui elle n'incite pas à
rechercher un emploi ou aux travaux
marquent c'est pas comme un chiffre je
crois que les français comprennent qu'on
a besoin aussi et que tout français a
peut être dans une difficulté un jour et
sera très heureux d'avoir des aides
sociales qu'ils éviteront la dérive dire
que les français recherchent le rsa si
on voulait pousser le raisonnement
l'extrême rsa 550 euros grosso modo par
mois j'étais présent le conseil général
je ne pense pas que les français du nord
je ne pense pas que les français
considèrent que l'aide sociale est une
solution la dignité passe par le travail
tout ce qui concourt à favoriser le
travail notamment le prime et l'économie
se retourner ont créé deux emplois ont
créé des emplois mais excusez moi bureau
sûr mais on crée des emplois
au jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai bien vu quand
même que les chiffres de la croissance
était quand même un peu plus restreint
année prochaine
enfin à la fin d'année 2010 8 et encore
plus en 2019
attention danger et là vous verrez que
tout le monde acceptera les aides
sociales